الغارات لم تتوقف هنا على جباليا منذ ليله
امس وحتى هذا الصباح سلسله غارات كثيفه في
اماكن متفرقه في جباليا مما ادى لتدمير
عدد كبير من المنازل ووجود عدد من الشهداء
والاصابات وما زال عشرات المفقودين تحت
الركام وصلت هنا بعض الاصابات الى مركز
جبالي الطبي جراء هذا القصف المتواصل
والعنيف على جباليا الليله وصباح اليوم
القصف لم يتوقف حتى هذه اللحظه طبعا هناك
ايضا عشرات الشهداء احنا منذ الصباح منذ
الصباح ونحن
نستقبل الشهداء والجرحى اتحدث عن 20 شهيد
منذ الصباح ونحن في الصباح ما زلنا واكثر
من 25 جريح هذه حاله من الحالات الان وهذه
حاله خطره تم قرار بقطع الرجل
لكن لا يوجد
امكانيات فنحن نعمل بادوات بسيطه الاحتلال
يعني حتك جميع العظام وهذا لا يصلح معها
الا القطع والبتر هذه حالات منذ الصباح
اطفال جرحى هذه الغرفه ايضا مليئه
بالجرحى لا يوجد غرفه عمليات واحده في كل
قطاع غزه الحقيقه حالات كثيره جدا من هذا
القبيل لو دخلنا الى الى
هنا ايضا
هناك
حروق السلام عليكم هذا بيت ال النجار يعني
تم استهدافه بالامس
حروق دكتور درجه ايش الحرق هذا اللي عندك
في درجات ثثه درجات رابعه وفي درجات درجه
رابعه دره ودرجه رابعه يعني نتكلم عن
حروق عنايه مركز صعبه تحتاج هذه الحالات
الى عنايه الى عنايه فائقه فانظر واضعين
كرسي وكرسي ايضا ل للمريض ايش اللي عندك
يا ابوي كسر في الظهر عنده كسر في
الظهر ان شاء الله بركب لك جهاز بسيط
للظهر وان شاء الله بتشفى بتحتاج عمليه
باذن الله الله يشافيك ويعافيكم ان شاء
الله الله يشافيك ويعافيك طبعا هنا حاله
حاله من
الحلات استهداف بالامس من ال سليمان وهذه
الحاله يعني من ابنائنا من دار سليمان
بالامس كان قصف يعني عليهم عنيف ونسال
الله له الشفاء والمعافاه الدائمه حبيبنا
حبيبنا باركه الله يبارك فيك بركه بركه
الله يشفيك الله يشفيك الله يشفيك الله
يشفيك الحقيقه يعني بتتحدث عن وضع كارثي
صحي عمليه اباده جماعيه لا يوجد امكانيات
بامكانيات بسيطه ايضا الجرحى نحاول
معالجتهم على بامكانيات بسيطه ويخرجون الى
مراكز اللواء الحقيقه هذا هو انهيار
المنظومه الصحيه التي هدف الاحتلال اليها
اباده جماعيه هنا الوضع الصحي هنا في شمال
القطاع هنا الوضع كارثي جدا لا يتوفر اي
طواقم طبيه ولا يتوفر اي امكانيات لمحاوله
انقاذ المصابين انس الشريف الجزيره شمال
غزه